while fans would typically debate
whether sequels were in the works after
a requel like this we already know that
believer is just the beginning of a new
phase of the excist franchise although
the film's ending doesn't hint at a
clear direction for the next film
director David Gordon green has already
started talking vaguely about the next
couple films and what will ultimately
amount to a Trilogy if all goes well at
the box office in an interview with
collider he said that there are many
directions he and his team are exploring
right now the idea is we built a road
map that I think has so many different
avenues that we could take the world of
exorcism and possession is so vast as
the movie finds itself existing in the
world over the next few weeks I think a
lot of those questions will be answered
all we know for sure right now is that
there's a sequel to believer currently
titled deceiver set to hit theaters in